I have some actual good news related to
the women's March which has
unfortunately become very toxic and
counterproductive as a movement over the
last year or so the women's March is
replacing three inaugural board members
and co-founders who I've talked about
before three people who have been dogged
by endless problems of marginalizing
people who aren't the right type of
intersectional allegations of
anti-semitism marginalization of Jewish
women who want to be part of the
movement and I'm talking of course about
bobland Tameka Mallory and Linda Sarsour
Sarsour of course is now a Bernie
Sanders surrogate I told you that about
a week or two ago something that Bernie
should be 110 percent disassociating
himself from maybe this will push him to
do that there will be a new set of 16
board members coming in including three
Jewish women and a trans woman and a
whole bunch of other people now to be
totally honest this strikes me as too
little too late I the the women's March
name at this point is up quite tarnished
the relationships with historically
allied communities like the Jewish
community one of the forefront civil
rights advocate communities in the
United States historically it may be
irreparably frayed I'm not saying I want
it to be I'm saying it may be I'm glad
that Malory bland and Saur Saur are
going bye-bye but I'm just wondering out
loud not in a rhetorical sense but I'm
just wondering is this an organization
that is going to have a role in the 2020
election because you have a progressive
movement that's more engaged than ever
you have new coalition's of all kinds
that includes a very varied list of
groups that are ready to go and working
on the ground the women's March has been
dogged by these people it's become
extremely divisive and to be honest this
is also it's almost like too friendly a
way of cutting ties with absolutely
toxic people the three board members
have stepped down it's unclear whether
they were forced or not as it seems a
little bit soft the statement that was
put out by the women's March is
completely gushing about
the groundbreaking work and sacrifices
towards equal rights unless of course
you don't fit the right version of
intersectionality in which case you're
marginalized and it's also unclear how
much the people that remain or are
replacing them are fans of for example
Louis Farrakhan and the Nation of Islam
milieu with which Saur Saur and Mallory
at least then I'm not sure about bobland
were affiliated with I just don't know
and I don't want to belittle people when
they make the right decision the right
decision is that these three have no
business being part of a group that
claims to be about inclusivity and
egalitarian ism and all of that no
question about it at the same time it's
hard to see this and have sort of a
renewed enthusiasm for an organization
whose rallies have become sort of
secondary to the internal conflicts and
the discrediting of potential and actual
constituent activists and it is sad
because it started with at least ideas
that are really good ideas that I that
I'm behind the upside is that I do see
the momentum of the progressive movement
having legs in 2020 that go way beyond
the women's March and that's a great
thing the women's March at this point is
not going to be central to what happens
in 2020 it's all of the other
progressive activism which is so
widespread at this point in time and
that's a good thing we don't want a
prominent organization to progressive
activism that functions as a sort of
gatekeeper that says well Jewish women
they're not really intersectional in the
way that we want and now the question is
will Bernie Sanders disavow Linda
Sarsour as a surrogate a totally
divisive character she shouldn't be
involved with a good progressive
campaign like the one that bernie is
running and by the way I expected wholly
negative reactions to my segment last
week or a week before saying Linda
Sarsour should not be a Bernie surrogate
there was a little bit of that toxic
left that didn't like it but
overwhelmingly positive overwhelmingly
positive response to that and that that
may have been an area I would have
previously self-censored on so that's
great